you mentioned
uh we should be humble also in the sense
with the analogy to ants
that uh they might be better than us
so there's a kind of scale that we're
talking about and in the
in the question you mentioned the word
sentient
so sentience or maybe the more basic
formulation of that is consciousness do
you think
um do you think that this thing within
us humans in terms of the
typical life form of consciousness
is the essential element that permeates
other if if there's other alien
civilizations out there that they have
something like consciousness as well
or is this i guess i'm asking can you
try to untangle the word sentient
yeah so that's that's a good question uh
i think what is most abundant depending
on how long it survives
so if you look at us as an example uh
we are now we do have conscious and we
do have technology
but the technologies that we are
developing are also
means for our own destruction as we can
tell you know we can
change the climate if we are not careful
enough uh we can go into nuclear wars
so we are developing means for our own
destruction through self-inflicted
wounds and it might well be
that creatures like us are not
long-lived
that the crocodiles on other planets
live for billions of years they don't
destroy themselves they live naturally
and so if you look around the most
common thing would be
dumb animals that live for long times
you know not those that have conscious
but in terms of changing the environment
i think since i mean humans develop
tools they've developed the ability to
construct technologies that would lift
us
from this planet that we were born in
and that's something
animals without a conscious
consciousness cannot really
do and and so i you know in terms of
uh looking for things that are new
that that went beyond the circumstances
they were born
into i would think that even if they're
short-lived
these are the creatures that made the
biggest difference to their environment
and we can search for them you know even
if they're short-lived
and most of the civilizations are dead
by now yeah
even if that's the case that's sad to
think about by the way well but if you
look on earth
that you know there's a lot of cultures
that exist throughout time and they're
dead by now
the mayan culture was very sophisticated
died
but we can find evidence for it and
learn about it just by archaeology
digging into the ground looking
and so we can do the same thing in space
yes look for dead civilizations
and perhaps we can learn a lesson why
they died
and behave better so that we will not
share the same fate
so i think you know there is a lesson to
be learned from the sky
and by the way i should also say if we
find a technology that we have not
dreamed of that we can import to earth
that may be a better strategy for making
a fortune
than going to silicon valley or going to
wall street
because you learn you make a jump start
into something of the future so that's
one way to do the leap is actually to
find
to literally discover versus come up
with the idea
in our own limited human capacity like a
cognitive capacity it would look like it
would feel like cheating in an exam
where you look over the shoulder of a
student next to you
yeah but it's not good on an exam but it
is good when you're coming up with
technology that could change the the
fabric of human civilization
but there is uh you know in my
neck of the woods of artificial
intelligence there's a lot of
trajectories one can imagine
of creating very powerful
beings uh the technology that's
essentially
you know you can call super intelligence
that could achieve
space exploration all those kinds of
things without consciousness
right without something that to us
humans looks like consciousness
and there you know there is a sad
feeling i have that consciousness too in
terms of us being humble
is a thing we humans take too seriously
that it's we think it's special just
because we have it but it could be a
thing that's actually holding us back in
some kind of way may well be
you